non non non non on va se faire à qui a
la plus courte en une fois salée quoi on
va jouer direct pour le son de glace
c'est quoi le jeu il est très ça on va
tirer chacun un morceau de bois
celui qui aura le morceau de bois le
plus court prendra ce sont deux gas dans
le docteur attention c'est chaud alors
on y va
choisissez sur une fois on dit c'est
ouais moi aussi je veux dire je commence
alors la malaisie frédéric tout le monde
joue
[ __ ] je la pousse alors on verra on
verra après tant d ouvrir après
bah moi je la sens très mal quand même
babychou croyons qu'il est plus grande
balandrade
non je vous jure tu sais pas ça c'est
plus petit ben voyons ya derrière
différentes et bat sara choix entre vous
deux vous ses bouddhas dans la merde
alors invite les gens et moi tu es l'un
vertes note aussi l'ajout de savoir
qu'est censé lancer le truc ah bah ça
peut te jette en faire un petit je vais
t'en faire un petit nom mais je vais
t'en faire un petit et allez c'est parti
est-ce que vous
pour joshua a laissé parler je fais ce
que j'ai un jeu moi tous en même temps
lui faire mal et il a raison allez on y
va j'ai fermé ma gueule
pourquoi tu l'as pas par la viola
apparemment je suis je suis sauvé les
gars a fédéré caire il fallait je fais
le petit mais je vais vraiment dans la
plus courte
[Rires]
il aurait alors fait une dernière allez
c'est parti
ah oui on s'emballe là je la sens bâle m
non non non il est capable dans le nord
s'il est capable maintenant la non non
non non
[Applaudissements]
c'est un coup dur
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]